2022年1月1日
皆様明けましておめでとうございます今年
も宜しくお願い致します
私はずシャツを1年間米ご飯を金銭してい
たのですが今から食べたいと思います
いただきます
この日をどれだけ去年から待ち望んでいた
ことでしょうか私始めたさなんとマイ箸を
準備させていただきましたこの大橋普通の
箸とは違いますてかなり大きな太めなお箸
になっております私肇社長はこの日のため
にお店に行っても何が選び抜いた貴重なお
箸那覇バキッという音がなってしまいまし
た
入れた感じでこれを橋が折れてしまってい
ますね鎌倉時代からお箸が折れる月が非常
に良い6悪いことと言われております私は
もう今年て終わってしまうかもしれません
気を取り直して食べていきましょうラティ
の選び抜かれたお箸は割り箸に変わって
しまいました
まずは白子がに手を伸ばす見せかけて
大好きな旧道を食べにいきますうわぁ
私が今回選んだのはすき家の牛丼並1月1
日間違いなく今日作られた牛乳がみなみと
盛られた牛肉の荒波を見るの1年ぶりに
なります私はゼロシャツをかけてきます
そうしていただきますという声を受けて今
や晴れ運命の瞬間の運営と新金谷バイバイ
バイ
いただきます
弓道口に運びました
1年ぶりのバーン彼からはどんな言葉が
出るのでしょうか
をしかめている1年間のつらかった日々を
思い出すかのように
何思う
彼から聞き取ることができたがたい異性で
なく鼻水をすする音感動のあまり涙を流し
ているのかしっかりと旧道をかみしめます
[音楽]
辛がった台上につながったツナ缶さが出て
きてまいります私は閉め社長は根っからの
牛丼好きで普段だったら週に2回は弓道家
さんに顔よほどの牛丼好きでございました
今年は一度も行っておりませんこの花を
ご覧下さいうーんなぁ
まるでが思春前だったかのような勢いで
ご飯を口に運ぶ肇社長もう彼には誘導が
食べ物ではなく命に見えるのです wnn
横からでいったんストップして今回は私が
的な候補いろんなものをゼミしました次は
城郷ハンド見てかけてお寿司今回の措置は
中トロとさあも準備させていただきました
高級なお醤油を準備してこれが中トロか
サーブがわかりませんが醤油20分今私の
釣りに口の中に落ちが運ばれましたそう
ac の香りとか以前のプラボレーション
今や靴の中は初日の出を迎えた日本海
まだかまだかと次のお寿司を早速商品
ディップにどんどん靴の中で運んで行く
はじめシャツを消して私お寿司自体が好き
なわけではありませんが1年ぶりに食べた
今年はとっても美味しかったです
からまさみの存在を忘れていましたさあ
いよいよ来ました日本といえばコレ白ご飯
この国に生まれてよかった1年前には
当たり前に食卓にあったご飯がなくなって
今帰って帰宅する中に運ばれました彼は
この懐かしい味を曲の中で頬張り何を思う
のか o 女は1級唾液の中に含まれる
消化酵素の効果丸十と呼ばれるあないとに
分解されているのですこれも1年ぶりなの
で甘く感じるのではないでしょうかう
ううう
むうむううううここが俺の場所なそうシミ
柄のようにご飯の中心に穴を開けていく肇
社長この動きとなればもう出てくるものを
アレしか無いでしょうドン朝といえばこれ
卵そして専用の醤油この味を忘れてはや1
年も経つかと思うと居ても立ってもいられ
ないコストで隠しておきました卵かけご飯
tkge は卵ご飯の上に乗りました
そして専用の醤油をかけわー
卵と将樹としてご飯をしっかりと混ぜて
いきます登場しました金色に輝く tkg
卵かけご飯をあげますさあ今いただけます
がかかりますこの場はされて1年以上もう
口の中が卵かけご飯を欲しています後輩が
隣で卵かけご飯を食べようとしていた時
殴ろうとしたのはいい思い出です
のばやばいやばいやばいやばいやばい
やばい本当に教えるこれまでのメニュー
じゃないか築き方そう肇社長が舌下で
卵かけご飯を食べて育ってきたのです
うまいやすいはやい
この三拍子なさにはもってこいの卵かけ
ご飯これを食べるの1年ぶりもう我慢が
できずに沈みたいところなのですが
まだまだメニューはあります続いて出て
くるのこちらカレーライスです今回は
淡路島カレーを注文させていただきました
淡路島カレーはビンゴやパパイアなどの
フルーツ鶏ガラスープデミグラスソース
スパイスを合わせたカレー淡路産の玉ねぎ
に関しては一年前に玉ねぎ1個使っている
という贅沢さ甘口のカレーが好きなはず
社長にとってはたまらない逸品口の中で
カレーの桜美味しさが広がっていくのが身
を持って感じれることでしょ
しっ
普通に美味しい
なかなか食べるときにほっきっていう人は
いないでしょうよっぽど美味しいん
でしょうねうーんそんなおいしい淡路島彼
は一旦置いといて最後に食べるのはこちら
ですオムライスです今回はただの同じでは
なく p 出場を懸けたオムシチューと
いう形を取らせていただきましたで巡らす
ソースのシチューがしっかりとか買って
いきます黄金色に輝く月んです私もとから
結構村井生産者にいくタイプだったんです
が去年は一度も言っていませんさあそんな
ですけどグライスを口に運び今彼は何を
思うのかうんさすがにこれだけ食べると
ご飯には来てしまったのでしょうか普通の
方が僕の食欲が止まることなくこれだけ
贅沢なごはんのメニューをどんどん食べた
てそして
[音楽]
もうながいっぱい食べ過ぎました
愛とけど無事お米ご飯禁止生活1年間終了
しました
ず分残ったが兼松教授に食べますやお腹
いっぱいなぁ
米って肌が膨れるなぁあの疑ってる人い
ないと思いますけれどもちゃんと1年間
ガレットを込め白ご飯記述させていただき
ましたさすがにそんなで途中で食べる
みたいなつまらない真似したくないし僕の
イースター b たらわかると思うんです
けどマジでほぼラーメルパスターその2票
でへと今年1年間は生活させていただき
ましたお米木一新してどう生活が変わった
かっていうとなんか体感そんなんわから
なかったんですけどとりあえずラーメンに
逃げましたねもう週に3で深夜とかに
ラーメン口に入ったりしてて健康的には
結構良くないような気がしたんですけども
何度トータルで犯すとかも普通に食べてて
よもう普通にご飯食べて旦那変哲のない
生活してるんですけどもなぜか体重が3
キロぐらいできましたすごいないラーメン
で週3とかで食べても体重産業を言ったん
です横引きんしたせいかわかんないんです
けど何カッ
なぜか体重が減りましたいやーなんか別に
お米食べなかったから堅固になったらそれ
がちょっとよくわからないんですけども
あのめっちゃつらかったあ僕そもそも
すき家とかカレーライスとが大好きに出る
ので
する1年間我慢したのが本単に自分よく
やったなあって思うせすごいつらかったし
食べたかったですねそのつがさを紛らわす
ためにもラーメン逃げたっていう1年間
だったかなと思いますけどまぁ改めて一年
ぶりにお米を食ったんですけど本当に
美味しい品が一瞬でお腹いっぱいになった
なって思いますもびっくりするぐらいば
お腹いっぱいで腹持ちのいい食べ物なのか
なっていうのと日本人に生まれて良かった
なというかお米がおいしい地域に生まれて
良かったらって改めて思いましたあのもう
辛すぎてカレー i カレーライス食べ
たい時はもう何でカレーを食べたりなら凸
オートミールに逃げてるといいそんなこと
してきたんですけどこ名は一番美味しい
です別に毎日食べたいってわけじゃない
けど食べたい時は食べたいって言う本当に
貴重な食べ物かなと思いますねお米って
いうのはよく頑張ったよ1年間もいろんな
人に迷惑かゲイたんですよどっかご飯に
いこって話し合ってもあごめん俺ご飯無理
だからって言っていうかお寿司屋さんいけ
なかったりとかカレー屋さんダメとか結構
あったので周りなどに非常に今日与える
縛りだったかなって思います体調的に何か
が辛くなるとか悪くなると感なくいたって
普通だったしなんなら体重が減ったって
いう感じでございました
[拍手]
どうとしませんそれとやっぱ様をはじめ雪
をよろしくお願い致しますじゃんっ
あっ
[音楽]
ハール
えいっえいっ
は